sandpipers of nevada swim club making
international waves after the united
states olympic trials three teammates
all
native nevadans qualified for the 2021
games the desert
really becoming a hotbed for swimming
talent john treach caught up with the
ladies before they represent the united
states proudly in tokyo john welcome to
las vegas
swim city team usa is taking 26 women to
tokyo
and probably impressively three are from
southern nevada
make no mistake every ounce of their
history has been earned with their hard
work
but these ladies also bring personality
to the pool they are 15
16 and 20 years old and they are
absolutely las vegas legends
erica sullivan bella sims and katie
grimes qualified for team usa this past
week by putting on a show at the u.s
trials in omaha
their star power is increasing with
every day and with every dominating
performance
but their home and hard-working
foundation is here in the desert
the olympics are a couple weeks away and
they can't wait to rock the red white
and blue
this is the dream this is what every
swimmer
wants and for me to actually get it and
earn it it's
very like satisfying and relieving
honestly
i got the gear the other day and i was
like oh my gosh
in heaven um but yeah
definitely like the just wearing the
flag and like having to represent them
is awesome it's weird when your dreams
become a reality and i think we're
definitely learning how to cope with
that
and it's a lot of emotions i think an
important thing about all this is that
we feel all those emotions
and really sink it in so that we don't
leave at the end of august with regrets
and
we get to look back and really enjoy
this whole thing
their hair is still wet because they're
always training three friends
three different olympic stories one
giant collective smile
it was an extraordinary setting today
we'll have a feature tonight at six
as well as an individual piece on each
lady coming up friday saturday
and sunday